[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you just tapped into the group chat live
in the bleacher report app
presented by fanduel i'm greg ivory
alongside sam richmond welcome to the
show
my guy
thrilled to be back here man last time i
was on the show we gave out some winners
you gave out a bunch of all-star game
winners that i think is a little
underrated so hopefully we can do it
again
let's do it again brother but it's march
3rd and you know what that means right
sam
it's trading man this is this is
exciting let's let's be great man
that's right it's trey day we are
celebrating the all
we're celebrating the three all show
long and our friends over at fanduel are
hooking us
up in celebration of trey day any fan
who places a 25 bet or more first basket
score wager will get a one dollar bonus
in sight credit for each three-pointer
scored in the game check out fanduel for
the rules sam who do you like
for first basket
tonight there's nothing quite like a
first basket dart throw i will go with
and this might foreshadow my pick a
little bit for tonight but i'll go
jayson tatum know jaylen brown they'll
get tatum involved early we'll go tatum
i like that i like that i'm going with
my man uh steven adams get the tip give
it to job find him on a pick and roll
give me steven adams but if that isn't
enough as always we're giving away locks
we're giving away hoodies and we're
giving away an iphone sam
should we get this thing going brother
let's go man amazing slate i'm excited
man let's do it
let's get this thing going i need
everybody to get in the comments because
i need gifts i need emojis but most
importantly i need winners only please
please please please in fact i'm going
to give out a jersey right now
i'm in the comments looking for a good
take i see uh i see jay hearn 23 says i
can't wait to see the warrior sons
western conference finals and he bucks
eastern conference finals these will be
two insanely good series that will
probably go seven full games of
superstars what a treat jay hearn love
the take love the take there we're
we're looking into the future he was
talking about the western conference
finals and the eastern conference final
stand so we're gonna give him the jersey
but it's tnt basketball thursday which
means
we are betting the three by two the
question is will there be two three
pointers in the first three minutes of
tonight's game we're running it back sam
the 3x2 parlay we're running it back we
got boston taking on the memphis the
clippers taking on the lakers and this
one's boosted up from plus 320
to plus 420. the question is will there
be two or more three pointers made in
the first three minutes of each of these
games get in the comments and tell us if
you're riding sam talk to us talk to the
people what are you thinking
yeah i mean i gotta say
taking with how the lakers have played
recently it's a little scary to have to
rely on them for this
but i will say plus 4 20 absolutely
great number and it's trey a so i'm
hoping those vibes will take us to
victory
we are writing the vibe sam and i've
rode the vives a lot and sometimes the
vibes will take you there we need that
to happen tonight so uh we are all
riding the three by two parley but
let me hop into the comment sam cause i
gotta give away some hoodies and i see
brady brady p13 says yes ja and tatum
will each knock one down lebron and monk
will each hit one shout out to you brady
for the good vibes thank you very much
you are walking away with a hoodie uh
and and i got namdi prince says there
will be four three pointers field goals
made in the first three minutes
guaranteed those are also good vibes
shout out to you 90 you are walking away
with the hoodie sam it's time to talk
major markets money lines against the
spritz and point totals for tonight's
game let's take a look at the odds sam
what are you seeing here and what do you
like
yeah i feel like this is probably not
gonna be the most popular pick but uh i
really like the celtics tonight look
they're 14-3 in their last 17 games i
think they've really found their
identity and who they are i know people
are probably going to be scared off a
little bit no jaylen brown tonight but
they're at home it's a short price and
they did just come back
had a second half come back against the
atlanta hawks without jaylen brown their
last game so uh i like that i think the
thing i most like here is look no one is
going to shut down john morant right now
the guy is on an absolute tear
that said i do think the celtics are
really well equipped to kind of slow him
down a little bit with their perimeter
defense you have marcus smart you have
derek white i think they can make life
tough for him make jaw work and i think
the celtics get to win
so yeah i'm piggybacking off of that sam
you you're talking about making job work
and play defense so i want to look at
the total in that game sitting at 223
and a half yeah there it is saying that
223 and a half and i want to look at the
under the memphis grizzlies have gone
under in the last three games and and we
just talked about the defensive presence
of this boston celtics team and how
they're gonna try to slow down this one
so i'm gonna rock with the under here
but i'm in the comments because i want
to know
what the people are picking or or what
they're even talking about br betting is
in the comments saying it's jj's
birthday y'all so
he might come out ready to play it is
his birthday i got uh king elvis's
grizzlies
moneyline number one team against the
spread in the nba okay shout out to you
king elvis uh i also have jones jordan
they got a jason tatum gif in the
comments
uh so shout out to you
i'm giving away one more one more one
more i got dodo bird one says
uh
celtics hot tatum built different
i'm rocking with you so uh you were
walking away with a hoodie as well we
talked major market sam it's time to
talk player props it's time for lock or
not i'm gonna put up a prop and i need
everybody
and i mean everybody to get in the
comments and tell me whether it is a
lock or
not
sam let's get right to it first up is
john marant to score 30 plus points
tonight
do you like this one do you think this
one is a lock or not
i'm i'm going no here i think we just
touched on it right i think the celtics
really good defensive team i think they
have really good perimeter defense i
think they're gonna make life tough on
him
that said i'm also not rushing to bet
the under on mariette just because
obviously i mean the last few games not
only has he scored a lot of points i've
been on a tear he's also getting about
25 30 shots up these last few games so i
think even if the celtics do slow him
down and make him less efficient he
still might shoot enough to where he's
going to get over 30. so i'm staying
away here but i lean under
sam's stand away and i'm i'm right there
with you i'm right there with you simply
because
uh
we've been talking about
boston celtics and their perimeter
defense and what i like to do is i like
to connect dots
we've been talking about their perimeter
defense we've been talking about uh how
they're gonna throw multiple guys at
john moran possibly slowing him down in
this one
but i also want to make a point to look
at this value 30 points at -102
i usually in the 30 range you get plus
money we're sitting that -102 here sam
i'm cool i i i don't want no parts of
this one let me hop into these comments
though let me hop into these comments
because i see uh stizzy new new york
city says celtics defense could hold him
to like 29 i mean that mean yeah that
that would be under uh shout out to you
stizzy nyc you are walking away with
hoodie dave dennison45 says lock not
that means that uh they're not rocking
with john marant to go over 30 in this
one so i guess we'll have to see but
next up we have jayson tatum to make
three or more three-pointers sitting at
plus 124 sam talk to me talk to the
people do you like this one
yeah i mean the the plus money here is
definitely intriguing and i think right
we touched on it no jaylen brown
probably means tatum is going to have to
carry the offensive load for the celtics
and he's shot 22 threes in his last two
games now he hasn't hit a ton of them
but the volume is there and he's a good
enough player that i three for ten
that's not that difficult so uh at plus
money i'll i'll say yes here
usually when the volume is there
everybody usually when the volume is
there that's a good thing that that's
usually a good thing sam so i'll just
say that before what i got to say next
but like a couple weeks ago we we had
patty mills on our parlay and we were
one leg away from hitting and it was a
patty mills three point uh
a bet and he was supposed to make over i
wanna say three
and my guy patty mills let us down sam
and since that day i said if
i'm only betting steph curry over three
plus three pointers made uh this year so
if this was next year maybe i might take
a gander at it because of the value that
he does shoot but this year i'm staying
away from it but i'm in the comments sam
i'm in the comments seeing what they are
talking about uh colin colin frost says
jt3s is a lock take it greg
maybe colin maybe but i know what it's a
lock you are walking away with the
hoodie i also say uh
i also see davin daven in the comments
devin perowski says yeah i can see it
but i like his assist better he likes
jt's assist better shout out to you two
you're walking away with hoodie uh
finally we have steven adams to have 10
or more rebounds samus sitting at minus
124 talk to me
talk to the people do you like this one
i do i mean you it's
not too complicated you look at his last
few games i i think he's has 35 rebounds
in his last two games and one of them is
21 so
only need 10 and minus 124 not a crazy
price i mean i think i think you got to
take it right what do you think
uh let me just list off 14 21 17 and his
last three
i like it sam i like it go grab ten it's
in that minus 124 i like this one but
i'm in the comments i'm in the comments
seeing what they are talking about and i
see uh slim picking 17 says john morant
is going off again
he's fading on us i mean we said stay
away from the point in total but he said
slim pick and he says john moran's going
off again shout out to you slim pick and
you are walking away with a hoodie j23
cash says adam's 10 plus rebounds is a
lock for sure shout out to you two you
are walking away with hoodie all right
it's time to build the br betting custom
same game parlay which you can ride with
us on fanduel tonight we are looking at
the clippers lakers game and of course
it is trade a so we are looking at the
three pointers i need everybody to get
in the comments and tell me what they
think which legs are locked which legs
or not sam let's get right to it the
first leg of our same game parlay is my
man marcus morris
to make over
two made three pointers tonight do you
like this leg brother
yeah i do he's been shooting it well
recently he averaged two and a half
threes in march and i think and we
talked about earlier greg right like
marcus morris is a big time big game
player and i think with the lights
bright against the lakers another chance
to kind of go at their rivals i think he
shows up tonight
i think he shows up too when the lights
are bright my man marcus morris usually
shows up moving on to the second leg of
this parlay we have lebron james to make
three or more three pointers tonight sam
do you like this one
yeah so i think this was the lowest odds
one in the in the parley i want to say
this is around -108 so a little scary
here um i will say like i think
the lakers are going to be desperate
tonight like they're obviously getting
clown on social media every day for the
last week uh i think lebron is going to
come out hungry i know i think he knows
they need to win this game and i think
he knows his team isn't very good so i
think we'll get a lot of attempts from
him tonight i wouldn't mind seeing him
in one of those heat check modes where
he just dribbles down and shoots uh
corners the top of the three because
he's feeling it so uh and it's trey day
so good vibes
it is trey day it is trey day
sam uh moving on to the next leg of the
parliament we got nick batoon
my man all he has to do is make one sam
all he has to do is make one do you like
this one
yeah so on the other end of the spectrum
i think this one was like minus 600
right so this is this if this doesn't
hit we are we are really a lot i mean
yeah he averages
uh two to a game i i think he gets at
least one
yeah
come on make platoon he has to get one
up tonight uh in the last leg sam the
last leg reggie jackson reggie jackson
two three pointers made tonight hey
reggie jackson is another one that shows
up in the big when it's big time big
games
and the lights are bright reggie jackson
shows up can he get it done for us
tonight
yeah i think you said it another guy who
i like in this spot and again i think
when you look at this parlay right
reggie jackson averages two threes for
like a lot of these guys if they just
hit our averages and we get a little
extra motivated lebron tonight uh it's
gonna catch so yeah we'll get two threes
from reggie i think i hope
yes yes yes we are riding the vibes but
let's pull up the ticket because i want
to show you guys if we were to put a
hundred dollars down on this parlay you
will be walking away with
360 dollars and don't forget about the
five cent sam but before i get into the
comments what are you grading the parlay
brother
well i appreciate that you caught out
the five cents because uh every cent
matters in this game but uh but yeah i
mean i think i was on the show a few
weeks ago we had a parlay i graded an a
you told me that for good vibes we like
to grade the parlays at b minus so it's
trade a good vibes i will go with a b
minus grade
sam's giving us a b minus because we are
riding the vibes yet once again for the
same game parlay but i'm in these
comments sam because i want to give away
some hoodies but i'm also giving away a
jersey here to a lucky fan in the
comments giving us a good take and i see
uh
spicy dubs is back in the comments spicy
dubs is back in the comments sam morris
is making at least two three-pointers
lebron is for sure making at least three
pointer at least three three pointers he
taking the over but but tomb isn't
making a three pointer
jackson can get it done
wow spicy dubs those he was leading me
to believe that those were good vibes
but then he threw the curve ball in he
got you at the end that is okay
that is okay the minus 600 man it's
tough
that yeah the minus 600 but that is okay
because here
on the group chat we turn bad vibes in
the good vibes so i'm sending you a
jersey of your choice spicy dubs uh i
also see also see j23 cast as braun goes
off marcus goes off
tatum's going off morris is a one shade
shout out to you j23 cash you will walk
away with
thanks for the vibes uh
let's move on sam because i want to talk
mvp
we're we're over a halfway through this
season and we've seen some crazy
performances a lot of guys from a lot of
guys so far so uh you think we got a
tight race for mvp now sam
this is one of the most fun mvp races i
can remember just because the odds have
fluctuated all season i mean there was a
point in time when steph and kd it
seemed like it was just them and they
were the only two contenders and now
steph if you look at this list seth it's
further close to the bottom kd got hurt
it just it's wide open it's really
exciting
it really is wide open and um i need
everybody to get in the comments and
tell me who you think is taking the
title of mvp this season these are the
odds you guys see them sam who are you
rocking with
yeah i think it's it's probably the
boring answer right he's minus 125 right
now but it's hard for me not to go with
embiid i think obviously he's having an
absolutely insane year that the numbers
are video game numbers but i think the
thing i like most here is grant it's
only been three games but him and hardin
that team looks absolutely unstoppable
right now
and if they keep that up and they make a
real push for the one seed it's hard for
me to see him not winning it especially
when you look at jokic the next closest
contender the nuggets are fighting for
the sixth seed
if the sixers are in that one or two
spot uh it's hard for me to see him be
not winning it
sam is rocking with embiid uh
yes sam i i like that
but i've been rocking with steph curry
all year i've been rocking with him
since the beginning i was rocking with
him when he was the favorite
and my man is plus
1900 right now sam that's kind of
disrespectful to wardell curry but i
want to say he is getting his team back
draymond's coming back james wiseman
supposedly coming back andre iguodalas
coming back and i also saw a stat sam
that said in 2021 steph curry in april
he averaged
39 points i believe it was somewhere
around there it was it was somewhere
around
29 points but anyway he had a great
month in april that's the point
and i think that that can happen again
because it's just a runaway he's just a
runaway he's in the top team uh his team
is second in the west so
if they go on a run i can see steph
curry i'm trying to i'm trying to make
it make sense sam that's all i'm trying
to do i feel like he's trying to make it
for my man steph curry
yeah i was gonna say i feel like he's
almost like a victim of his own success
because he started off so hot and
everyone expected him to maintain that
level which is a little unsustainable
and just how good he's been in years
past where this might not be his best
season but that's not his fault that
he's amazing every single year that
doesn't mean he doesn't deserve to win
mvp but yeah he's not dead yet he's
still alive
he's still alive yes he is uh i'm in the
comments though sam i'm in the comments
because i'm giving away some hoodies and
i see uh
jacob jojo 47 34 54 right now i think
joking deserves it but embiid probably
will win it
yeah ah
i think mb deserves it over jokic i'll
be honest uh
jones jordan says babyface assassins
steph curry yes he is the babyface
assassin uh and mess splash says says
wardell curry all the way shout out to
everybody that i mentioned you all are
walking away with hoodie speaking of job
around we all saw
that game on monday my man played out of
his mind 52 points four for four from
three and that crazy buzzer beater at
the end of the game is it possible john
morant wins mvp this year sam
so i think he's definitely wait wait
wait wait wait i'm sorry
no i'm sorry sam i'm sorry not just mvp
but also
most improved player with the mvp
okay yeah so i think he's definitely a
lock for mip i mean yeah the odds are at
minus 750 right now it's i unless he
gets hurt which like knock on wood uh i
just don't think anyone has a chance at
catching him i i think he has a chance
to win mvp and i'll say this i have a
bet on morant from a few months ago at
40 to 1 to an mvp
the that my hesitancy especially at the
numbers that he's at now
is that the grizzlies are 12 and two in
games where he doesn't play
and
you know i think he should be higher in
the odds i think he should have a better
chance but i think some voters who
really take the award literally and say
most valuable are just gonna see the
easy cop-out and say okay they've won
without him at 12 and two how can you be
the most valuable player i personally
think that's a little unfair to draw but
uh i do think that kind of does hold him
back here
unless he continues and does what he's
done uh the past few games and stacks up
some more 45 50 points if he does that
and goes on like a a kobe or
durant-esque pair from a few years back
then i think he has a chance but
it's just going to be tough man i think
it is going to be tough but hey like i
said for steph curry all john needs is a
runs him he just needs to go on a run
and his team goes uh they jump the
warriors in the standings possibly the
sons and next thing you know java rant
might be the mvp of this year but you
guys know what
usually i give away
some more hoodies at the end of the show
but since it's trade day i'm giving away
an iphone so i need everybody to get in
the comments and give me some takes
i'm in the comments right now and i'm
looking for good takes goat garden says
if job puts up crazy numbers he will win
and i agree with that i just said that
if ja
goes on a run and puts up crazy numbers
and they jump the warriors and possibly
jump the suns
i can see him winning mvp
uh
snoopy he says it's a small chance sam
he says it's a small chance but it's
there so the the comments
they they they're rocking with ja
duis 44 says ja is locked in for mip 100
d wise
you are walking away
with the iphone for that take right
there you agreed with my man sam sam
just said it he's locked for the the
award you said he's locked in so i'm
giving you an iphone
shouts out to you sam it's time to get
up out of here bro it's time to get up
out of here thank everybody for tapping
into the group chat presented by our
friends
over at fanduel remember what you
learned today the 3x2 is a lock get on
fanduel and tell our br betting same
game
uh trade a special same game parlay and
the trade a bonus over there at fanduel
we'll be back thursday giving out more
hoodies more jerseys and more locks if
you want a hoodie today we will dm you
alongside the man the myth and the br
betting sharp legend sam richmond i'm
greg ivory we are leaving the group chat
peace
[Music]
foreign